the future of this beacon of
international cooperation may be in
doubt
when the war in ukraine prompted the
west to sever nearly all ties with
russia the international space station
was one of the few exceptions
three two one now after more than 20
years of partnership russia says it's
pulling out
of course we will fulfill all our
obligations to our partners but the
decision to leave after 2024 has been
taken i think that by that time we will
begin to form a russian orbital station
and lift off
to many this move was a surprise
nasa and the russian space agency had
only just signed a new agreement to
ferry astronauts to the station
in may the head of the european space
agency said cutting ties with russia on
the iss was technically impossible
both sides are responsible for different
technologies on the station and neither
is trained to operate the others without
assistance
it's going to cause problems um
the the russian sort of side of things
is in charge of several key systems
onboard the international space station
um probably one of the most key ones is
its propulsion system so that's the
thing that stops it from uh because it
it's just about in earth's atmosphere
and over time its orbit does slowly
degrade and it gets closer and
occasionally it needs to get it's all
bit boosted up again and um the russian
segment is responsible for doing that
first through the hatch is denise
matavian since the war in ukraine broke
out even life in space hasn't gone
untouched by the politics of earth
in april questions were asked about the
russian crew's choice of spacesuit which
matched the colours of the ukrainian
flag
they denied any hidden messages but many
saw it as a protest against russia's war
in july the russian crew made a much
clearer political statement
they posed for photos with the flags of
luhansk and donetsk two russian-backed
breakaway regions in eastern ukraine
it's unfortunate that the politics on
the ground have now reached up into
space before the iss was the one common
ground that we had where
you know it was in everyone's interest
that at work and we never neither side
used the iss for
these kinds of political posturings for
events on the ground
the iss was first established back in
1998.
research on the station has led to
breakthroughs in battling cancer
alzheimer's and heart disease
monitoring natural disasters from space
has also helped relief efforts here on
earth
but with russia and china now planning
to complete their own space stations in
the coming years
a period of space cooperation may be
giving way to a new era of space
competition
vincent mulligan al jazeera